cat tip like I was walking in how's it
going cat you might know cat from
various shows on Fox News I know her
from Greg show yep she's always on
Gutfeld yeah so you got a podcast on
barstool sports yeah how did that come
about they saw me on Fox News and they
were just like you should do podcast
yeah I was defending a sorority video of
girls dancing around like in bikinis
with glitter on them I was like I they
seem to be having a good time to me was
it a video video podcast um I know
mm-hmm is there a better way to say
video podcast that they saw you and they
just said we want to hear you know that
was on Fox they saw me do that on Fox
right so I'm saying that the podcast is
just on it's just audio they call it a
vidcast if that's a video play really no
well there's a comedy Katie Nolan as a
combination of she started the podcast
but then became video right I should do
that but I like to just come in looking
like garbage when I do my podcast yeah
you'd have to come straight from fox
news and leave your TV makeup on or
something happens
I wouldn't you could just you get up and
do it put your hair in a ponytail you'd
have to come all dressed up yeah I get
like hair dysmorphia we don't have my
weave in now nowadays is that right I
got it in right now that was like a
mermaid your hair no no I'm wearing five
tracks of clips right now are you
kidding yeah my hair's like this short
she put she's putting them to her her
shoulders yeah short hair yeah once you
leave it short which one I mean it looks
good now but what's wrong with shorter
because I didn't know this existed like
I'm not really somebody who knows things
about hair and makeup I started working
at Fox I was like everyone's hair is
like so beautiful and they were like oh
honey like that's not their hair yeah we
should put it in your hair I was like
what I don't know how to do it myself
though I bring it in a little bag and
then I clip it in for I did it feel
I can't even notice it anymore oh you
don't can you wash it and just like
blow-dry it
oh yeah you wash it oh I do wash it you
know no but I mean it seems to me so I
you can always tell the difference you
can feel it and a lot of times in the
back of the head you can feel it like
weird comes up a little bits real human
hair I don't know who's watch you screw
your hair because it's I don't have very
good hair which what your hair doesn't
grow very very fast is it thin then
you've been here I do when I was dating
I dated a black girl in high school and
I made the mistake of running my fingers
through her hair at one point she's like
you can't you can't do that was all
prax I was going to ruin everything
everything so is it uh how thin is your
hair I'm fascinated with this I mean
it's then it's then it's blind blonde so
it's you know thin okay
have you started Fox News I wrote
columns about you know political
correctness type of stuff and they had
me on a couple times and then I met Greg
and I was on redeye and then when he
started a show you wanted me to be a
correspondent co-host whatever on it so
that's how I got hired hired that's cool
weekly shows yes Saturday's right yeah
Saturday's at 10:00 p.m.
yeah mm-hm are you know really great on
the five yeah yes yeah he's pretty much
like the one of these he's the main guy
on yeah I was like why was he leaving
redeye he's so good on a red-eye but now
you see that this is a bigger show cuz
when they have it with us on five
o'clock in the afternoon instead of
three o'clock in the morning yeah but he
was you know now is yeah there's any of
his picture on the building now he does
does he finally have his picture on the
building the house big I just see his
face so often all the time I don't know
yeah yeah I don't know why use mm-hmm so
uh do you find yourself or you are you
were you invested do you feel like you
would've been invested in the election
or is it something that you now have to
keep up with because you're a news
personality I mean I've always followed
politics now I follow it more obviously
just cuz it makes my life easier to not
look like prepare like as much for each
individual segment if I know what's
going on but this one I mean obviously
everybody was paying attention kind of
had to but not as much attention as they
showed up on our girls yeah are you are
you surprised with the reaction people
have I am I'm also I mean I would I'm
also not because I mean people were like
you know even Obama the president was
like the fate of our republic depends on
this dude not getting elected here he is
right and what are they saying this be I
didn't see Obama's speech that he speech
like noon yesterday or today right after
ready Hillary's concession yeah what did
he did he actually make a speech I never
saw yeah he said that the we we hold
dear and it's very important to the
peaceful transfer of power yeah and then
you also which I can't wait I think
either today or tomorrow the meetings
yes today it's today right it's gonna be
awkward it's gonna be real awkward he
specifically said you know with Romney
or McCain at least I thought the whole
country wouldn't be ruined but this guy
will ruin the country
hey guy that I told the is that I was
gonna ruin the country bigot trumpet
said some really unkind things the worst
president of not some really nasty [ __ ]
you know the whole the whole birth
certificate thing yeah people that's
we're they can talk like that about each
other and then they sit down at a
meeting and they get it it's like they
both understand this is what we do when
the game is they don't know though
because this one's different cuz you're
right about like the birth certificate
thing and everything Donald Trump has
been a thorn in Obama's side way longer
than this [ __ ] election yeah
oh my god yeah absolutely oh man I gotta
be the president I was telling you I
don't think he I think he's probably a
little bummed that he was there yeah I
do he want to win right but like you
know his house gets smaller the Air
Force one is not [ __ ] compared to the
jet that he's going around in all the
time already given again security he
loves security guys oh my god she's
coming in and nothing better is a guy
that having other men talking to their
sleeves when you show up that's being
powerful course it's probably got to get
to pick his own nickname the Secret
Service is gonna call him you know they
got code name everybody yeah she's
probably gonna like to know actually
something damn make it up they have to
make the president doesn't get to pick
his own nickname he picked up confound I
said no that's not appropriate mogul is
his first of all why do they even have
code names if everybody knows what they
are also obviously when there's a bunch
of Secret Service guys are saying the
Eagles on his way you know who the eagle
is right yeah right yeah and they're
talking into their wrists like no just
use a [ __ ] walkie-talkie you say be
always comment we know if that were me
I'd make everyone do that though you
would that's probably the most fun part
talking into their wrist me J's Carlos
Bill Clinton was Eagle Oh God Donald was
mogul and she was Musa McCain was
daredevil uh what the hell is that they
probably picked his own he that one I'm
sure he did how about Harry oh that's
what the president should be Harry yeah
I really couldn't tell Tim Kaine and
Mike Pence apart physically you came out
they look the same to me
they both look I mean they both look
like the the stereotypical older white
guy I mean I could pick it in a lineup
but but look at that am I the only one
that's like you know
they they I think they're very different
looking but my Pence is a more dignified
older looking eye although I like Tim
Kaine more like Mike Pence's religious
yeah I don't like that he wants to shock
gay kids I don't love that about him he
doesn't want to shock him yeah he's okay
with the with the fixing of anti gay
therapy for children which you know
that'll make everything better and
definitely not way worse traumatic and
make them not be able to love themselves
forever right
right I think Mike Pence looks like he
looks like they both look like crazy
people yeah but Mike Pence looks like a
put together very in control Patrick
Bateman serial killer he looks like
Leslie Nielsen and nuts did you see nuts
[ __ ] Barbra Streisand kills him
because she's a hooker
and he wants to keep partying he's like
what are you gonna do [ __ ] somebody else
shows him the piece of glass
yeah but I've never seen that but that
does sound like something I would enjoy
yeah yeah that does look like oh wow oh
yeah I see that
and then I mean I mean Mike Pence and
then Tim Kaine looks like uh like he's
just got a screw loose just walking
around kind of nuts I mean he probably
he probably has no plans no you know he
was going to be the vice president we
here's poor Tim Kaine he got thrown into
this yeah so a year ago he was gonna be
regular old Tim Kaine yeah then he got
thrown into this and now and he was
talking to his wife and they made plans
like what's what's gonna be like to be
the vice president check it out a DC
location oh yeah oh yeah googling every
night what power the vice president has
what I'm gonna be able to do he said you
see this picture Joe Biden looking all
cool eating ice cream and holding $10
bills that's gonna be me mm-hmm
no he's got to go back to his regular
life I still can't I mean I can't
believe it you know I remember how funny
it was when Donald Trump announced he
was gonna be probably oh okay all right
he just came outside a bunch of racist
stuff rise like yeah and I'm gonna make
his speech was so long everyone else was
like really really long and he's at he's
going to be the president yes going to
happens the president-elect you know you
I don't understand why people can't
laugh like I get why it's disturbing and
all that but you have to laugh you've
got to I mean that's a hell of a
career trajectory like any apprentice to
the most powerful man in the world
plus they tried they threw everything at
him they were like here's a tape of him
saying he wanted to grab women by the
[ __ ]
here's here's this is a wait he lied
about this everything he ever said they
were like here's evidence of him not
abiding by the he said he's pro-life
here's a tape of him saying he's
pro-choice
he said he was against the war here's a
tape of you saying he's for the war and
everyone goes ah that tape was awful he
was saying I have and do sexually
assault women and then he was laughing
but people hold on like a Dave Chappelle
pointed something out which no one else
caught yes he goes when you're a star
they let you and that implies consent
that's not sexual assault I mean in
terms of the just grabbing people and
kissing them part oh wait he was all
guessing but grabbing the [ __ ] fella I
read a quote I should probably what a
[ __ ] smart thing to pull out to say
that he's obnoxious quote but yeah I
mean I can't believe that Billy liked
Billy Bush got fired and drunk at the
presidency Billy Bush they're like I had
the Today Show and now I got nothing
yeah I mean well you know when someone
says some stuff it's offensive and you
know you laugh along if you're
interviewing like it so I feel every
time I interview Nick DiPaolo on my
podcast hey you know be that's just what
you do you know you're not gonna be like
well actually that's problematic sir
like that's just that's not you can't
interview somebody under those
circumstances but here's really people
are sick and tired of being told you
can't hang an American flag up or if you
were an American flag t-shirt during
Cinco de Mayo or during whatever it is
offensive its offensive and it's
aggressive and if you have a flag in
your cubicle somebody complained that's
the culture that people are tired of
it's being told that everything you like
and everything you believe is offensive
and everything you think is wrong if you
go outside when people rebellion those
red white and blue Zubaz it's a trigger
oh yeah yeah that's what career rigor
everything's you know like cap okay a
lot of college campuses are you know
professors or cancelling exams and all
that kind of solidarity for elected a
lot of them are not happy I was
surprised that most costumes approached
Trump yeah yeah they loved they loved
her I mean canceling I don't touch with
the youth yeah phase the celebrity the
college kids will love them they all
watch The Apprentice because they got
all the celebrities all together
I could understand why you know if you
were you know somebody from a certain
demographic especially you'd be upset by
this but stuff is upset I wake up every
morning very upset for you know at some
reason at least but you come work not
sense Trump just in general just in
general just like my personality yeah
you wake up with is it up setter is it
dread I kind of wake up I usually wake
up with this weird dread yeah and go
like okay we realize that once again
it's a woman next year sorry about that
well he might keep doing this to myself
yeah but you go about your day and you
point out that like it's kind of
ridiculous so maybe it's funny yeah you
got a laugh yeah if you have to laugh at
anything yeah the therapy dog
Tufts University what [ __ ] wimps yeah
why do you say that at the University of
KRT crash run offer the University of
Kansas from - student via social media
of therapy dogs available for comfort
every other Wednesday what college do
you think in colleges job is to provide
a comfortable place for you it's not no
it is a job is not to provide a safe
space for you is to get you ready to go
out and be a [ __ ] adult and a teacher
it's not to provide a safe space and
there are adults if you're a college
student you're 18 you're you're not to
go to war you're old enough it's not
their job to provide a safe space for an
adult because this is going to be this
is why people get out of college right
and then they go to work and the CEO has
like a big company-wide meeting and
they're like I was thinking maybe every
other Wednesday the company could
provide therapy dogs like you want a
puppy room just in case work gets too
hard you can play with some puppies for
awhile now companies wouldn't even say
no to that they would be like well okay
let's weigh the options and you go to
human resources yeah and the next thing
you know they'd be a [ __ ] dog in the
room because Human Resources afraid
you're gonna sue the company for making
a hostile work environment imagine you
know calling into work and being like
look I'm really upset about who the
president's gonna be in January so I I
can't make it yeah well you shut up
right oh you don't get to do that I did
love the protesters last night that were
yelling impeach Donald Trump and alike
and he's not the president and he hasn't
done anything for as a president yet
he's got a like you can't impeach he's
not gonna be the president for two or
three months yeah
the people were really like I said I did
the 3:00 a.m. shift at Fox coverage on
election night yeah as I was walking
over there people were just I'm like on
the street just bawling and like look
like there's people with like their
faces on the ground like that like just
laying there sobbing and like rubbing
each other and I was like was there like
likes I look like like somebody died it
looked like you know but it was this
they just saw a whole family get hit by
a bus yeah one of the people laughing as
well no I mean you know you can't I was
kind of just like okay yeah ever so I'm
really big on it's very important to me
to pretty much I cry in private right
you know right my big you know unless
you know if you're like sometimes if you
know drink a little too much and you're
crier when you drink oh I can be I can't
be no I hate it it is the worst I agree
i GP yeah thank you whatever my birthday
is the worst birthday ever
how often do you cry when you drink I
mean uh not often but a little too often
to say not often well are you uh now
when you're in relationships you tend to
cry about the stuff that's gone wrong
when you're with the person like you get
drunk and then let them know your dream
is on whether or not I think it'd be
advantageous or not you know I'm like do
I want to cry in front of them or not do
I air grievances oh I like live every
day like it's Festivus 100% you do I do
yeah airing of grievances all the time
I'm just walking around airing my
grievances at all times none when you're
dating someone though does it take up a
bar you know a bunch of drinks to make
you tell them are you a good talker I'm
a good talker I mean is that good though
I think that I would be more successful
in relationships if I talked to us why
cuz it's just too much yeah I mean
sometime you're not supposed to voice
every single complaint right like you're
supposed to maybe compromise every now
and then and when it's big enough
address it but if your everyday just
being like I hate when you [ __ ] do
that if you talk about it does you know
you want to hate it like if you're not
happy with your birthday will you tell
them order to come out when you're drunk
that's what I'm saying is like there's
something I want to go hear you do that
no
ya know I try not to do that I get more
angry than I do
weepy but you know yo but you'll say you
turn the waterworks on when you think
it's advantageous oh yeah I'm sometimes
that's dangerous it's bad I'm bad but
you know I just fighting although you
know I've been in my most recent
relationship which is the same circle of
fights over and over again
mm-hmm you know about what oh you know
you will you were talking to this person
well who is this person when you're
talking this forum well you remember
this person him saying that are you
I'll bother just back and forth back and
forth okay so you're jealous and then
you meet somebody who's also jealous
yeah
oh yeah you both did yeah is he cheating
uh nah we started as like you know good
friends and so we know everything about
each other's past okay which is good
that you know we're friends but then
it's bad cuz you know everywhere all of
us as humans are nightmares right you
know like horse if you know someone well
enough you're gonna know they're garbage
which is why you shouldn't you know you
know dating your friends you should date
somebody who you know not well enough
you get to keep a facade of I am a
beautiful princess right and I have
never you know a little smile and that
would be better for me you know what
people tell me my biggest problem in
relationship is what's that I care too
much
yeah me too I work too hard our
relationship yeah
sick terrible job interviews and to
giving you many what's your flaws that
your previous employers have said well
you know I don't know when to turn off
my work life and start doing personal
life I just work all the time work too
much you don't play enough yeah
absolutely
why don't you get out of the office you
big you know do you ever leave sure you
dumped your ex oh he dumped you
oh it's been a sight a circle of uh you
keep dumping each other that's great
yeah are you still kind of in and out in
and out will say yeah yeah that's the
fun of having or are we friends are we
dating now or we know it's all a
nightmare everybody I should have stayed
in a Detroit everyone's married and has
two kids but it's good to kind of have a
friend because they know you and you
know them so the fact that there's no
surprises can also help you both know
like all right we're hunks of [ __ ] yeah
something to that were like you know the
big reveal never happens because you're
both kind of like alright I already kind
of knew that yeah absolutely that's that
that's kind of true are you a nightmare
to date yes yeah you are can be I mean
I'm
yeah you know I'm not boring today I was
the master of its own makes you a
nightmare oh she's well I really do need
the other person to be obsessed with me
but then I also kind of need my space oh
you want total control over the amount
of contact but you always want it ready
when you want it yeah well it's kind of
like if I'm texting like I'm crazy I'm a
Scorpio I don't even believe in that
except for like it does fit here I'll
text you a million times and if you
don't answer me I'll be like I'll move
to another platform like I'll go on
Facebook Messenger and I'll go on this
and I'll be like I saw your active on
minute ago what are you doing but if you
do that to me I'm like what's your
problem
right doc chill out so did that ever be
working if you have that level of
self-awareness I do you ever try to
correct the problem I do but I'm also
very impulsive right sometimes you just
want to make the bad feelings go away
and the only way to do it is through a
text messages yeah lots of them yeah and
eventually it goes wrong it does go
wrong Oh Mike I've ruined so many things
in text I try to get too dirty or I get
to nose here I get whatever text can
ruin you because you just whatever you
think you're sending out consciousness
text messages and never realize good is
there anything worse by the way that
when you're doing something you had a
bit of a tip with somebody and you open
your phone this is like nine new text
and it's just like paragraph after power
and you're like oh you [ __ ] all this
yeah I do that I do that I'm like you
send the giant text yeah I do not and I
will edit them you know I will go
through them and I'll edit them oh my
gosh uh also I will you know send drafts
of screenshots you know drafts to
friends and be like what do you think
about this one like I will add this it's
enough oh my god yeah you're covering
your face with your hands is way too
dramatic I know it you kind of have a
lot going on now like guys see me I
guess you're still writing columns like
yeah wouldn't you just want to stop all
that nonsense
you would think I would think but it's
life fuel that's what that's what my
friends and family all say yeah they
know you're obsessive uh I think so I
mean they I feel like it'd be hard to
ignore
I don't know right you guys got that
vibe right away right away
not really I didn't know what you know
and if you didn't say it I mean I've
never seen you interact
but I probably wouldn't have asked if
like my assumption was that you were
very easygoing and just Pleasant in a
relationship I probably wouldn't have
asked if you were a nightmare
I mean I can be you know like I'm you
know I can be I do have the thing is I
do have my own thing going on like I'm
not like someone who'll ever be defined
by a relationship or be like what are
you doing what are you doing like I
can't hang out every night right right
absolutely so I but I can still find a
way to smother you from afar did you
catch ever catch him doing anything he
shouldn't do text message he should he
should have sent that was kind of dicey
uh yes and no I don't know I kind of
just don't really look when you said yes
or no what did you catch him doing that
you do your dad I don't know about that
you know it's I just be like who's this
you what were you doing who you talking
to like why were you up at 3:00 in the
morning it says you were active on
Facebook four hours ago
you know it's all you check when they
were active you're a problem yeah your
problem Jake you think your goose would
be cooked Oh [ __ ] not really because
people know getting involved with me
it's going to be a [ __ ] show right no
one goes into it with me expecting great
things but you know I've dealt with that
too they check your your activity or
your would Isaac come on
yeah give me a [ __ ] but then again I've
done it too I just haven't said it they
all talk to somebody and I'll send him a
message and I won't hear back from them
to be like on Facebook Timmy they're
[ __ ] two minutes ago they never got
back to me [ __ ] them so you notice I
feel like you know when people tweet
when they didn't respond to my text it's
like alright fine you just don't like me
I thought that true that I'm like I've
done it too and I'm like never thinking
of the other person when I do it I'm so
annoyed when they bring it up like so
what do you want
did you change too because like I would
imagine now and any guy that you're with
would have to know that you have a lot
more options because you become a
problem creates a lot of problems right
that creates a lot of problems
especially like the Fox News fans
because the Fox News fans know that like
they hire all hot chicks so they watch
like they fall in love with the
correspondence and I see cuz anytime we
have any of the of the women there on
Fox News on here like you see all the
Fox News groupies yeah I have Fox News
and I've bars - all right so I'll have a
bar stools all athletes and like
athletes all of athletes hitting me up
or whatever and
guys so and that'll create a lot of
problems to like--that's or you know
he'll be like you have all these other
options and I'm like I that's fact
what kind of worry your hop on you would
anyway like what you know an athlete's
hitting her up she's would have access
to them maybe not but women is the word
access all the time you've access to
this yeah that would make kind of
relationship here I don't want I don't
know I don't want to do anything to
identify this puzzle okay we just said
that's fair but he's not a public person
no is he in is he and uh he's not a
television personality okay so he
doesn't have a sec yeah I don't think
ego can date ego but like I get I found
everybody's such an eagle there you go
it stands for easing God out I do I get
yeah yeah that makes that make sense I
mean that was a bad joke oh no it was
true yeah yeah my if I was dating
somebody who was like the fun girl that
talks about sports that athletes like
like it would drive me [ __ ] crazy
that yeah howdy terrible how they hit
you up on social media yeah they'll do
they'll follow if they follow you to see
if you follow back and then they'll
slide in the DMS oh yeah so that you
know that's how I got you on this show
you followed me and I slid directly in
here D exactly yeah
but you know quickly if that's good I've
done that too and a lot of times doesn't
work like somebody's not interested you
can tell that uninterested and sometimes
they might be interested it's fun it's
worth trying you need to watch sports
why are you following them why are you
it's fun you know it's a fun thing like
hat like even like uh like I I wanted to
go to the Danny Brown show and like I'm
from Detroit on a huge Danny Brown fan
it's amazing he's a rapper from Detroit
I was [ __ ] Islip I slid into his
d-ends and I was like do you wanna do my
podcast and he was like I can't but like
you know he invited me to the show and I
like went back and we like hung out all
night right and you know I'm like not
like hook up with Danny Brown it was
like really fun and I know everything
and and then me and this being this guy
were like on an off time when this
happened and I'm she just looks at his
face because I want that I did that like
I am actually like empathetic to that
but he thinks you're [ __ ] Danny Brown
I'm not
I'm not make out with him no it was it's
sad but you know if I was no he's great
Danny's like really cool like fun but
you also like when you slide into
somebody's DM and they're like I'll come
to the show and you're like yeah for
sure
even if you were dating this guy the
time even if you weren't on an off
period you couldn't it be tough to be
like oh and can I bring this dude with
me because it's like oh right well your
boyfriend wasn't happy you were hanging
out with that guy I guess all your
boyfriend doesn't have a boyfriend
I haven't had a boyfriend technically
for about a year and a half okay so he's
a guy that you see he really has no
right to sing on again ah yeah that's
what I'm saying the other night yeah
does he want to be your boyfriend I
don't know this is really bad nobody
listens nobody listens to it it's not a
popular well you're not saying anything
bad you're saying you don't know what
your status is right I care about this
person and that you slept with Danny
Brown that's right actually it's
phenomenally it's not true even true I
make you pretend it wise yeah for my for
my brand do you think that'd be good for
my brand absolutely I'd like to say I
know it's not true but if it were true
Jim would you want her to share the
intimate details with you while you were
in intimate moment you would yeah yep
you like that yeah we yep I'm really
happy about that so if you found out
that like your ex or your your on-again
off-again whatever was hanging out
backstage with Danny Brown you'd be
pissed and then you would masturbate may
we depend on that you know I don't like
a recognizable face I say like in dirty
fat I prefer like anonymity like I don't
want it to be a syllabus no like there's
no girl I've ever dated that like what
we should have sex with this celebrity
it would hurt me on right no my
girlfriend wants to get tea-bagged by
Liam Neeson want to know that right I
don't I don't really think about it that
much I was kind of just like I want to
go to this concert tickets how is it can
I bring my friend Sabrina this is fun it
was a 1 and he was really nice really
thought we showed each other pictures of
like our cats you know do you text I do
with him um sometimes yeah cool just you
know how's Detroit people right right
yes that's the hond
yeah Danny Brown word is bond that's
those bad yeah San huh
so 3 to 5 a.m. yeah doing election cover
yeah
I mean I guess for this one because you
walked in I kind of thought this
election and I said it was going to be
boring I thought it was gonna be over
Somali night I told you you were wrong I
guess right yeah no that's true you said
it's gonna be an early night
Hillary I did say was Gabriel I thought
to do I thought I was gonna just stroll
on in there and like yeah we gonna be
watching yeah yeah and instead it was a
very emotionally intense experience were
you on when they actually called it it
was late I went to bed like one day
right right before like I went on right
after Oh after everyone was like well
Wow and then we're on things you know
Democrat it was like therapist you know
their prey is that right or do you like
Trump or you're not a Trump person I'm
not a Trump person I'm also not a
Hillary person I'm not it I just was you
know the whole election season was just
like what what the hell you know did you
enjoy the show the show the whole
election I mean that's the only way to
look at it yeah uh it's it's terrifying
but also it's like what are you gonna do
yeah what are you gonna do but laugh you
have to laugh I I you anything can be
funny no matter how bad it yeah so yeah
what you want with megyn kelly I I was I
was one uh you mean ever like I was
before like towards the end of election
season but not election night I like her
a lot yeah she's great you like megyn
kelly
yeah she's married with kids but
otherwise I think she might be great
yeah that's the only thing stopping you
guys I'm sure yeah you think yeah all
right I feel like you too but you know
phone Li she said that right she's like
oh I wish I wasn't married have you seen
Jim Norton
yeah that's bet it was short hair you
think so yes I do I don't want you
beautiful either way but I think she
looks better with short hair I see her
face better and it's very rare that I
would have greeted that almost all the
time when again she looks good there too
good god yeah she does but you know what
she probably look okay in that position
even if she what did she do when she did
those saucy and might I say
inappropriate uh what did she do back
there was she still on Fox back then I
was she modeling
no she was on Fox poked I think it was a
GQ spread or something yeah yeah but she
was on Fox wearing a dress I do well yes
it's a very great tight thank you right
now yeah yeah very good earlier that her
bosom is almost showing she's wonderful
lovely so you've liked doing the the
barstool podcast too it's so much fun
the barstool that they moved to New York
and now the office is a it's a bar it's
sponsored by like Bacardi Oh cart and
it's there's just like I don't even know
I'm not good an estimation I'm a girl
you know not so much math a lot of like
walls and walls of these folk art and
people should know they just drink in
there and fun there's a live podcast my
pockets no it's not live no I mean light
from a light audience no but I should do
that yeah I like to perform bring people
in how does a added Fox react to you
launching the podcast do they care about
like what do you say don't don't don't
go this far nor do they or do I think my
own anxiety it keeps me from generally
going too far yeah like I'm gonna leave
here worrying about this but you don't
do I didn't say anything bad at all you
just talked about relationships and
being a little bit uh you know that was
normal stuff I know you know just you'd
hate you hate to be vulnerable yeah you
know yeah that makes you more
interesting when people see you as a
complete person I think it makes them
more interesting and people connect to
you more and they'll you know I always
find that I don't like somebody who just
has a persona never interesting I'd like
more real people and more interesting I
kind of just can't help myself so that's
good news yeah me you just like to cry
and stalker I think it's funny yeah I
don't I don't
well I guess stalk I mean stalk implies
it's in parties didn't know I was phone
stalking for two years but it does that
yeah but that's like stalking it's very
invasive but I know you're saying is you
tend to be a bit aggressive or invade
yeah it's not stalking yeah no no no a
digital talking a little bit a little
bit you know I want to know what's going
on yeah exactly
you just want to be informed yeah I'm
just you know information that's
happening we're invested camera in your
house so what was it what was it what's
the vibe like by the time you get to
like 5:00 a.m. like what's that 4 to 5
a.m. our like of election coverage
because by then everybody knows
everybody's exhausted by it everybody's
trying to sleep I guess but not on the
west coast too though so you know should
know a little bit earlier there yeah I
mean people were I think people were
still not accepting it I mean people
weren't very much in denial they were
trying to figure out like okay no this
will be like mm they're gonna go back on
it but it wasn't even close no wasn't no
I wasn't listener by like eleven o'clock
when they were like yeah we don't know
which way Florida is going to go but
it's very heavily
and so is Ohio and Michigan and Michigan
it was too close to the next day but
they called [ __ ] like the New York
Times whatever app they're using what I
they said that artificial intelligence
is picked like the last four or five
accurately and they said it was a 91%
certainly like 11 o'clock I was pretty
impressed and some point too because
they were like a handful of professors
that were going on TV and going uh well
you know oh it doesn't go with any of
the polls but we've predicted the
election accurately every year for the
last twenty years based on this
mathematic equation and this says Trump
is gonna win yeah and everybody was I
get that far yeah motivation they say it
was like no there was there was a whole
algorithm of amount of media coverage
and amount of money spent madam money
brought in an amount it was all these
factors that get added all together
wasn't this the first time that the guy
spent less one when this I think so but
it was also like he had much more media
coverage yes I'm sure that cuz you know
he couldn't stop
no just couldn't no no I mean it was the
right move obviously but I get why we're
fasting people like why are we was
talking about Trump because a guy who
was a reality show star who's never been
in politics is now the most powerful man
on earth yeah I get why it's fascinating
yeah you know it's it's interesting yeah
absolutely it's something that deserves
to be talked about for all of time like
it's it's literally they tried they
Obama's election was historic it's the
first black president that is a thing
right but like this is easily the most
historic election of our lifetime
Hillary must be so mad I mean yes I
can't even imagine how upsetting that
must be to lose to the guy whose
previous job was the host of The
Apprentice I'm she's humiliated I know
she is that's how much they hate me at
the end of course she's humiliated right
oh how could this happen and you're
right what you said before it's like you
could protest it you can be mad about it
and that's cool but like you can't sit
around and act like an injustice was
done yeah as we played by your rules
Hillary we play by those rules that you
have done for what is it 50 years or
however long
has been in politics like weed it was
completely by the book politics since
the 70s yes yeah she was on on the
Watergate hearings so she's been she's
been here since the 70s I know it's in
previous election you know even when she
was running you know against Obama and
the primaries was like discussion of is
it sexist to call her Hillary and the
Trump comes out he's just like crooked
Hillary he only calls her crooked
Hillary I was like this is unbelievable
yeah yeah right crooked Hillary Clinton
she's probably sleeping it's okay like
on bully
it was everything he said was like a
roast of something or something right
for kid Hillary Hillary Hillary you know
she doesn't have the stamina she doesn't
have the energy for I don't think she's
gonna be anything yeah I don't know what
kind of president I make he maybe we
should be amazing he may be a disaster
but he uh just knowing what I know about
him as far as I lived in one of his
buildings at one point I know that
that's no indicator like president
France no but he really does run a
[ __ ] whatever it is people that were
clean do their jobs properly so we'll
see maybe that will translate look
Bloomberg was a very very smart
businessman and you know again it turned
in to make him a very good mayor he was
a good mayor so maybe that will work in
with Trump favor maybe it won't but
Bloomberg was better than anyone thought
he was gonna be and don't forget the
sneaky [ __ ] he did get the third term oh
yeah yeah I mean it was it was a term
limit he went back there and back doored
and got a little vote then got his third
term oh yeah so sad that all a lot of
people know about him is the whole you
know don't drink the large soda ban
issues all people really don't take my
son away [ __ ] yeah Drake a gallon of
soda at once everything like Jesus that
made me love him yeah I mean keeps
shaking the showroom that much no I just
love that he was doing that because
people who are big and fat it's about
them taking up like a medical uh you
know dollars for like the health issues
they have or for sitting on planes they
complain like you shouldn't it's not war
on fat people but I mean as a
libertarian I think is you know I'm like
obviously against that but at the same
time it's like you do understand the
reaction and why it was so strong
because if you are somebody who's
drinking an XL big gulp you need it all
in one sitting you can't just go get to
you know throughout the day if you want
no you can have some stuff you need to
know you need to I like a big soda cuz I
like knowing it's not going to run out I
like to know that I'm going to be able
to carry this with me I'm going to have
an hour or so or however long it is what
I'm not going to need a refill what did
you what did you think as a libertarian
would you think Jared Johnson nice guy
I like Gary uh Stella stuff with wealth
at the end was insane like there's
everything kind of fell apart
it really did um what the white wide
libertarian this was a great year for
them and they just [ __ ] shot not that
they would have won but it was still a
nice you know I want believe me I want a
third party just yeah what are you doing
yeah you could have gotten something you
could get more done percent well like
you said all the people all the you know
of people on Twitter that are like super
hashtag I'm with her like yep if you
voted for Gary Johnson [ __ ] you you're
not invited to brunch oh you died in a
fire you ruined it now we're all gonna
get exterminated it's like chill out
though a little yeah maybe you shouldn't
have [ __ ] Bernie out of the nomination
maybe you should have wanted fair and
square and his supporters wouldn't hated
your guts out that too it's exactly is
like you know if you're in the DNC at
you you ever think if you need to play
dirty to get this person through the
primary then maybe not the best for the
general right maybe yeah but I mean I
carry Johnson and take away any votes
from Hillary it has nothing to do with
why Hillary lost
no I'm although two percent that two
percent yeah but it's not like it was
all Hillary voters that voted for Gary
Johnson I think was mainly Trump bit of
it most of that 2% would have gone to
trump and believe me I do think you're
correct yeah yeah I absolutely think you
are correct
wait a minute is that a clue into what
your secret vote could have been no I'm
just saying I think you are absolutely
correct that people who would have
supported Trump over Hillary in a lot of
cases may have voted for Gary Johnson
yes even if they didn't like him I think
so oh so I'm speculating just as
speculate Jim is very secretive about
who we vote your because you don't like
to talk about politics politics on the
show yeah we're never done yeah yeah
I've heard it's very rude yes yeah yeah
it's a you know I hate that people
really live television like so any about
who you found far away you know yeah
I'll just can we just talk about my text
messaging habits a lot less personal
right guess who IDM yeah yeah yeah do
you send inappropriate photos no okay
is that because you're on a I'm scared
yeah I'm scared of like my iCloud
getting hacked or whatever like mark
it'd be bad enough with just even some
you know I text you know with all those
stream of conscious messages but yeah
I'm not gonna have that stuff out why do
you use the iCloud as a public figure
who people would want to hack into stop
the iCloud [ __ ] stinks back it up to
your computer and do not involve the
stupid iCloud that's how they hack you
yeah that is other hack you just stay
away from the iCloud it's not not
necessary I know it's gonna everybody's
gonna have to use the untilled
I will not use it until they figure out
a way I promise you they will launch a
phone that has like two gigs of storage
on it and they will say it'll just be
just put your photos on the icon that's
what Google jacketing not happening
until they figure out a way to you got a
lot of naughty photos yes why don't you
a lot you know you know he's got a lot
of naughty photos it's happened more
than once where Jim will be like showing
you something on his phone he's I guess
he that's what it looks anything yeah
I've gotten so many whoops what Jim well
the bottom line is until they figure out
a way to allow you to choose very simply
what you want to backup to the cloud and
what you only want backed up on your
phone to your computer that's how dumb
they are and how out of touch they are
with how [ __ ] vulnerable their system
is how about you have a way to save
certain photos only to your phone and
onto your computer literally an option
for like color-coded yeah I'll say it
public another how about this you push a
certain thing you can you could turn the
option off and then automatically back
them up to your iCloud if you want but
if you want to you can double tap a
photo and it will have a very thin
little green line around it and that
means that photo is on your phone or
directly the computer only no iCloud
backup this way you [ __ ] stuff if it
gets hacked you understand all your
private stuff the truly humiliating
things are not going to get taken and
learn how about this with the text
messaging yes how about you ever go to
text somebody and it's just sitting the
inbox for six months you like oh my god
they never got that yes how about on
your list of text messages they have a
color coding like a light blue tint or
something on the ones that have a
message in your outgoing box that have
never been sent we need to send you to
Cupertino dude on business you gotta you
know you know harder those
you want you know you want you what you
want instead of how about instead of
taking away the [ __ ] Jack that you
can plug your headphones I'll set these
on these yeah these lateral moving
[ __ ] with a [ __ ] watch how about
you make the iPhone a little bit more
effective and safer for people yeah
because yeah it's yeah I agree yeah okay
look I'm not using your iCloud I'm not
using it all these people who have
gotten hacked have all been hacked to
the iCloud you how many people probably
not using it for that reason
let's get Eddie Q in here and you can
tell what a piece of [ __ ] I shouldn't
have think of this I didn't graduate
high school you know how about you dumb
[ __ ] at Apple think of a way to
make your iCloud a little bit safer or
Google if you want to force people to
use this dumb cloud system right allow
them to keep certain photos only on
their phones I don't think it's I don't
think it's a thing that's stopping
anybody from buying phones no not buying
phones I don't think they're worried
about being a lot of people from using
iCloud I'm telling you it is stopping
people and think so
the fappening was a huge success it was
but after that when people saw oh that's
how vulnerable their system is because
you can hack into it as many times you
want until you get in with the phone you
only got 10 shots at it right emails
different like my dumb email there's not
a million things in there like the phone
is where it's at and the phone what 10
times in a recess yeah perfect can I
feel like we've we've all learned things
today either so I think I'd be a great
idea to build a you know color codes I
like to color I've been saying that for
a year I just not tell anybody exactly
to me like the Apple and the nudie
hackers are colluding together in a
conspiracy yes yeah because the bottom
line is you they just caught somebody at
Apple saving customers photos Medicare
that around that scares me to Scott and
I knew that was gonna happen that people
going oh then we're not allowed to I get
it yeah but you know tell me [ __ ]
scarlet johansson goes in there with her
phone to update to another phone and
some guy might not go oh [ __ ] I'm
keeping these yeah I saw Snowden they're
keeping track of everything yeah I saw
it you gotta protect yourself you do you
do I protect other people's information
yes it's not my I don't have any nude
photos of myself like that that are full
face to body yeah and nobody wants to
see my dick nobody cares about Jim
Norton dick file you want to look at it
good don't say that about yourself yeah
I'm saying try to make them care and
they won't I show people look my deli I
don't want to see that is harass my
brother but you know me I'm not a banner
of self-importance it's also other
people's information yeah absolutely
yeah I think that everybody's going to
be hacked when it's all gonna
something's going to happen I don't know
I have no and it's like I think like oh
you know people like well I don't have
anything on my I'm like do you really
nothing right nothing on your whole
computer I hate that argument while you
know I don't mind if they look in
because if you're not doing anything
wrong then you're not gonna mind if they
see what you're doing everything I've
ever done is embarrassing at least a
little bit you know like that it doesn't
matter if it's illegal or but just just
know refer to keep your business your
absolute how many people have said
things about their boss or maybe a cork
or a farm or whatever that you don't
want people to know it's not all about
sex you could just say something stupid
in a text that they grab yeah yeah
absolutely or you know find out that's
why that's why you didn't come to my
birthday party you're dead to me that's
it it's could really that meat stuff
like that does ruin friendships it does
it does well listen we're out of time
Omar by the way last thing here have you
ever like on your Facebook thing and you
see in the fee where they open your
photos to give you options oh yeah and
they're like no one can see this but you
are like all [ __ ] like we upload all
these now No
I almost did that to a Dropbox thing I
was like I know I unplugged it you did
yes just unplugging it through it [ __ ]
you I panicked I really did I threw it
like it was on fire off my bed very
scary because we cuz you want to upload
it into your Dropbox but they did say on
the Facebook no one can see this but you
I'm like thank God you know hard B to
explain how my dick is circumcised in
some photos and not in others cat people
can find your podcast on barstool sports
like I mean I'm great on Greg show
really great yes thank you shape that
it's on barstool sports it's the cat
temp show um we're going to tweet it out
at Jim and Sam show so you can get the
link and is there any Fox News
appearances I'll be on at 2:15 today
okay so that's where you can see caddy
yeah absolutely cool and next time your
next time you're over there in the
morning swing by I'm I just might that
sounds thank you and I got a bunch of
gigs just go to Jim Norton com if you
want to see